[Music]
straight ahead on lawn crime daily
a verdict is handed down for celebrity
chef mario batali it's an understatement
to say
that
mr batali
did not cover himself in glory on the
night in question a verdict is handed
down for celebrity chef mario batali and
the case of dr william husel it was one
piece of evidence that we never really
gave a second thought to that ended up
carrying the day for us we give you a
look inside the deliberation room in an
exclusive interview plus it became clear
to me he was like looking for something
proceeds to do a cavity search
conflicting testimony in the trial of
johnny depp versus amber heard but first
the murder of tara grinstead she
wouldn't have missed school and not
called in
so at that point in time i knew
it wasn't good jurors hear testimony
from grinstead's lover as ryan duke
stands trial for her murder law and
crime daily covering court cases from
coast to coast
[Applause]
[Music]
20 years after the disappearance of tara
grinstead the former teacher and beauty
queen's ex-lover takes the stand giving
jurors a look behind the curtain of the
relationship
ryan duke a student at the school where
grinstead used to teach now stands trial
for her murder the case gains national
attention in october 2005 when grinstead
went missing following a local beauty
pageant for years the case went unsolved
until the podcast up in vanish created a
renewed interest in the case by 2017
former students ryan duke and bo dukes
were arrested in charge in her murder
the pair are not related but were
friends of the at the time of
grinstead's disappearance prosecutors
say ryan duke confessed to killing
grinstead saying he broke into her home
and killed her after a burglary went
wrong after that beauduce helped burn
her body in a pecan orchard duke's
attorneys later said he was under the
influence of drugs during the confession
in 2019 beau dukes was tried and found
guilty in connection to grinstead's
death this week tara grinstead's lover
and a veteran police officer heath dykes
took the stand on direct examination
dykes explained his relationship with
grinstead and testified he cooperated
with law enforcement's investigation
were you married in 2005 when your
relationship turned to a sexual nature
yes
during that time period when you were
involved in a romantic relationship with
miss princeton how often would you see
her
maybe
twice a month
how often did you speak with her
we spoke daily
were you forthright about the kind of
relationship you had with miss grinstead
when you spoke with gbi agents i did
were you cooperative in the
investigation i was
through the course of this investigation
essentially until february of 2017 did
you consider yourself to be a person of
interest by the gbi
i think i was i
felt like i was being
and um do you know how many times you
were questioned by the dvi no
do you recall the gbi took any of your
devices such as your work computer
anything of that nature for evidence i
turned it over to them
my work station at work
a laptop
and cell phone
on cross-examination defense attorneys
zeroed in on the latex glove found near
grinstead's home that later tested
positive for ryan duke's dna dykes
explained he does not remember seeing
the glove on grinstead's property when
he visited the night she went missing
how many times did you cross over this
area of the yard while you were
investigating what was going on in her
house
[Music]
once going
to the house
and once going back to my car so two
times you crossed over that area that's
correct fair to say you were trying to
be alert to see if there's anything
unusual
uh in the art
yes
did you i guess from your statement you
mentioned you you didn't see anything
unusual outside the house right
now that was a jack-o'-lantern
that was lit up on the front porch
and that's the only thing specific other
than dolly that i remember seeing
and i guess
are you are you still of the opinion
that uh you would have noticed that it
was vlogging that had been there
hey you know
i think we're getting out of the vehicle
i was so fixated on the house
when i was walking to it you know
focused on
getting to the door to knock on the door
to see if she was there when i saw her
car there i was
kind of okay she's here car's here she's
here and went straight you know just
kind of i reckon lack of a better word
tunnel vision
straight into the front door your
testimony is that you walked over that
area twice
and you don't you can't say one way or
the other whether you would have noticed
it
okay i i did not see the glove
joining us today is criminal defense
attorney nicole de board and co-host
terry austin nicole with dyke saying he
didn't see the glove do you think the
defense may try to argue it's planted
evidence and would that even get them
anywhere in a trial like this
i think that the defense has to do
anything and everything they can to try
to mitigate the evidence that the
prosecution is putting on in this case
which has been incredibly strong against
the defendant so i think it's very
possible that they may argue look it
wasn't there somebody who should have
been a trained investigator was on the
property and did not see this evidence
so it must have come from somewhere else
and be potentially planted or unreliable
evidence you know that said i don't
think they will do much to to help the
defense i do however see it being very
likely that they might give it a try
yeah the fact that he's an officer i
think helps the defense just a little
but maybe not enough terry heath dykes
provided some interesting testimony do
you think it was more helpful to the
prosecution or the defense
well he was fairly neutral as far as i'm
concerned because i don't think he
really helped either team but if i had
to say which team i think he helped the
most i think kind of the defense and i
say that because look that glove is the
one thing that really does tie ryan duke
to this murder it was his dna on that
glove and so when this witness went to
the house to check up on her he didn't
see the glove and he testified as to
that he's a police officer the jury's
probably going to take his testimony
very seriously he cooperated fully with
the police and so i think his testimony
even though the prosecution brought him
on as their witness i think his
testimony
was very helpful as far as the defense
was concerned
yeah i mean any points that a defense
attorney can get from a prosecution's
witness is a positive in any way in any
case that you you try so let's see if
those few points they gather here can
help them as the trial continues
still ahead on law and crime daily what
went on inside your deliberations that
cleared the name of dr william
but first hollywood x's johnny depp and
amber heard face off who we could expect
to see on the stand next week
[Music]
welcome back when court resumes next
week amber heard is expected to finish
her testimony an unexpected turn though
as hers team will also call johnny depp
back to the stand
law and crime network confirms heard's
team will also call actress ellen barkin
and her sister whitney to testify this
comes as part of a multi-million dollar
defamation lawsuit stemming from
allegations of physical abuse heard
divulge in a washington post op-ed court
is expected to resume in the trial on
monday may 16th ahead of that we're
taking a closer look at depth and herd's
conflicting testimony last week heard
described an incident at the hicksville
trailer park where she says depp
performed a cavity search after an
argument now we want to warn viewers
this testimony could be triggering as
the clip discusses sexual assault
she kind of just leaned into me
and put her
you know head on my shoulder
and kind of grabbed my arm johnny
gets really
activated he gets really upset he's like
grabbing my my my breasts he's touching
my thighs
and he rips my underwear off
he was telling me we're doing we're good
we're going to conduct a cavity search
shall we
i
like
just shoved his fingers inside me
when johnny depp was on the stand he
gave his own account of what led up to
the argument on their trip
and so you removed kelly sue's hand from
amber and you yelled at kelly sue and
told her that amber was your girl right
that's not correct that's not correct no
sure you had an argument with miss heard
and you understood her to be upset with
the way that you had handled um that
situation with kelly sue correct i mean
i recall that
that was a a part of the argument you
would agree with me mr depp that
at a minimum you smashed up a bathroom
sconce during that argument correct
yes sir i punched i punched a um a glass
a
bathroom sconce
terry heard describes a violent sexual
assault that i'm guessing would leave
her in some amount of pain but
afterwards she acted like nothing
happened so how does the jury reconcile
that information
you know it's really hard not only to
reconcile between deaf and hard but to
reconcile what herd herself said i mean
she's saying that there was this violent
incident that he did a cavity search why
would he be searching for drugs they had
plenty of drugs there he did admit that
he punched this light fixture but he
definitely does not admit to violently
attacking her and she talks about
leaving that area and she left and
everything was fine she was talking to
her friends she didn't call the doctor
there was no indication at all
whatsoever that anything was wrong with
her and after a violent attack like that
you would think that she'd have some
repercussions from that yeah now nicole
what's the journey to do with this story
because amber heard starts off by saying
hey this is a weekend where there's
nothing to do we do drugs and i had just
done mushrooms so what are we supposed
to do with a story that comes from a
person who admits to doing drugs even
though she says you know what it didn't
affect me at this very moment
exactly i mean i just think that it is
not super helpful testimony for her and
quite frankly even as you're watching
her testify she's presenting with this
dramatic uh sort of
retelling of this event
and at the time as terry's already
pointed out she leaves she talks with
friends there's no doctor called uh
there's more drama on this witness stand
than there was at the time of the
alleged attack and we don't have any
independent evidence or anyone to verify
what she's saying and now we have all
this drama on the stand i'm not sure
that it's compelling especially combined
with the fact that she was on mind
altering drugs yeah i think at the end
of the day it's going to come down to
who is more credible in front of the
jury as more and more testimony comes up
of course it's going to be interesting
stay tuned to law and crime of course
we've got our podcast as well as other
uh streaming services that can bring you
this case that of johnny depp versus
amber heard coming up on law and crime
daily a verdict is handed down for
celebrity chef mario batali
plus an exclusive interview with famed
defense attorney jose baez and a juror
that helped acquit dr william
[Music]
welcome back we're getting a closer look
inside the deliberation room just weeks
after an ohio jury acquitted a doctor
charged with 14 counts of patient murder
prosecutors said dr william housel used
excessive amounts of fentanyl and other
lethal drugs on patient at mount carmel
hospital in columbus ohio between 2015
and 2018. while the state argued the
defendant murdered his patients husel's
defense team led by famed attorney jose
baez argued the doctor provided comfort
care to patients in their final days
throughout the week's long trial jurors
heard from husel's co-workers expert
witnesses and several family members of
the alleged victims in the case after
more than 30 hours of deliberation the
jury returned a not guilty verdict on
all charges this week law and crime
network's own linda kenny baden spoke
with juror damon massey and jose baez
about deliberations massey explained he
was one of two jurors that reached an
impasse
i said if i was a doctor i probably
would administer another dosage myself
so so that's when i said you know what
how can i fault him and if he's not
guilty of these three different cases
then how can i find him guilty of these
other ones that were so similar with
vent removal you know we remove event
you have to get on medicine was it was
it a little harder than what people seen
yes but you can't just prove intent off
of that the thing that he relied on to
switch his vote which was living will
was not something that diane or i had
even really focused on during the trial
so it just goes to show that this was a
jury that
that did its homework and and dug its
heels in and actually went through the
records
and really did a phenomenal and a
thorough job
terry you've litigated numerous civil
trials how important is it to find the
right juror
you know there are some people who think
that jury selection is the most
important part of the trial and i
understand that because they are the
ones who are going to decide the case
and you have to be very careful when you
select a jury and i've actually used
consultants before and they help you to
determine the body language whether or
not someone is lying whether they're
going to be sympathetic so it is
critical but you know brian at the end
of the day i think it's preparation i
think it's presentation that really is
going to decide the case yeah i would
definitely be one of those defense
attorneys say you pick the jury you pick
the case and uh it's sometimes a lot
better than the facts that you have
nicole was this the thought process you
guessed led to the acquittal and does it
make sense with the law and the facts
that it makes a lot of sense i think
that this was a much more difficult case
for the prosecution than many have said
and certainly when the prosecution
thought
i think this is one that the medical
community was watching and while doctors
certainly may have a different opinion
about how much medication is appropriate
i think many in the medical medical
community fear the prosecution coming in
and second guessing medical treatment of
this nature and the defense team did an
excellent job of bringing in experts to
really go through in detail the records
for each of these patients so this
particular juror hung his hat on one
particular aspect and there were plenty
of decisions that could have been made
by other jurors related to the treatment
of each of these patients leading to a
not guilty verdict in my opinion yeah i
don't think jose baez really cares what
the issue was that the jury hung their
hat on so long as it was uh a not guilty
end of the day but it's always
interesting to see uh the difference of
opinion between jurors and defense
attorneys especially when you get that
acquittal thank you both when we come
back closing arguments are presented in
the case of iron chef america star mario
batali what verdict the judge quickly
returns for the celebrity chef
[Music]
welcome back closing arguments were
presented and a verdict is handed down
in the sexual assault case involving
celebrity chef mario batali in bust in
boston batali who grew to fame through
food network in abc's cooking show the
chew was found not guilty of an indecent
assault and battery charge for the
alleged sexual assault of natalie tini
back in 2017. the two were at a boston
bar when tini snuck a photo of batali
over her shoulder he saw her take the
picture and ushered her over saying they
could take a selfie together teeny
alleged that the chef touched her
breasts butt and between her legs before
asking her to go back to his hotel room
while the two took photos the alleged
groping teeny testified too is not seen
on the photos shown in court in the
two-day long trial prosecutors called
only two witnesses and battali's defense
attorneys only called none actually on
monday the celebrity chef waived his
right to a jury trial so the judge made
the decision on the verdict announcing
it tuesday afternoon
this case is about credibility
and it's the court's job to
to assess the credibility of the
witnesses complaining witness
has significant credibility issues her
reaction and lack or lack thereof to the
alleged
assault is telling commonwealth has not
met its burden to the degree that's
required by law i'm going to find the
defendant not guilty to the charge of
indecent assault and battery
before the judge read the verdict
tuesday both sides presenting closing
arguments batali's defense attorneys
wrapped up their case first
mario battalio didn't assault
the alleged victim on april 1 2017.
he he posed with her to take some
selfies and that was it you've seen
you've seen each and every one of those
photos in the live photos those don't
depict any decent assault and battery
they don't even depict a simple assault
those photos and the video show an
entirely consensual encounter between
the two
prosecutors then gave their closing tom
the judge the victim came forward to
tell her story
was miss teenie really supposed to never
return to town which was her regular
hangout spot
because she'd been assaulted there
was she supposed to not go to italy
that single time
because the defendant was a part owner
of it
was miss teenie supposed to stop living
her life because she was sexually
assaulted by the defendant
she told you she was not going to do
that
she told you that she came forward with
this case so she wouldn't have to
nicole as a public defender i often say
acquittals are either
lost by the prosecution or won by the
defense so in this case which one was it
i think that it was lost by the
prosecution and that the prosecution was
stuck with the witness who had
credibility issues from the start
unfortunately and you know the
prosecution doesn't make the facts uh
they simply decide whether or not to
prosecute the case and in this instance
uh they decided to move forward on her
word but her word was just not something
that the court felt comfortable relying
upon
and proving a case beyond all reasonable
doubt
now terry the judge began his decision
by saying that battalion's conduct was
not befitting a public figure somewhat
weird i would just say not befitting a
person but whatever but then he found
batali not guilty why do you think the
judge came to that conclusion
you know it was interesting when you
listen to the first part of the judge's
statement it really did seem like he was
going to come down and say that batali
was guilty because he said that his
behavior was not becoming but i think
what he looked at was a couple of issues
first of all as we heard in the clip
there that the victim was not credible
that it was particularly disturbing she
lied about her jury service she said
that she you know
definitely
was disturbed and
frankly she wasn't and that was a lie
and so
the judge really didn't like that and he
also didn't like the fact that she tried
to evade a 200 club membership and and i
think the other thing is the reasonable
doubt as nicole has mentioned you have
to prove your case beyond a reasonable
doubt and there were so many doubts here
the photos did not show that there was
an assault so i think the judge at the
end of the day made the right decision
yeah and right decision by the defense
to you to go with a judge trial rather
than a jury trial maybe that change at
all here i'm not sure but thank you both
and thank you for joining us here on
lawn crime daily we'll see you next time
as we discuss justice in america
[Music]
you